في المقابل نقل موقعه بلوم بيرجع عن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه قوله انه لا يوجد مؤشر
على ان الرئيس الروسي الذي مربوط النيرغب
في اجراء المحادثات ذات مغزى بشان التوصل
لتسويه في الحرب الدائره باوكرانيا اضفت
اضفت وزير الخارجيه في حديثه محطه سين ان
ان الرئيس الروسي استخدم فصل الشتاء سلاحا
ضد المدنيين الاوكرانيين
ما يقوم به بوتن بالعمل الهمجي
استخدام فصل الشتاء سلاحا عبر تعطيل مصادر
الكهرباء واغراق الشعب الاوكراني في
الظلام وتعريضهم للبرد بينما هم مقبلون
على فصل الشتاء هذا حقا سلوك همجي ونحن
ندفعه بقوه من خلال دعمنا لاوكرانيا وتاكد
من حصولهم على الدفاعات الصاروخيه التي
يحتاجونها والعمل على تزويدهم بتجهيزاته
للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه التي يحاول بوتن
تدميرها